Tonight I ordered a targeted military strike
on the airfield in Syria
from where the chemical attack was launched.
Hi, I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason, we're talking
with Emma Ashford of the CATO Institute.
She holds a PHD in foreign affairs from University
of Virginia
and is an expert on the Middle East.
Emma, thanks for talking to us.
Good to be here.
President Donald Trump ordered a missile strike
against a Syrian airbase.
What's the likely outcome of this action with
regard to the Syrian civil war
and to US relations with allies in the area.
To some extent it depends on where this goes
next.
This strike appears to be something of a one-off,
that Trump is portraying it as, you know,
'we are hitting the Syrians hard, a punitive
action
to show them they can't use chemical weapons.'
Which was the proximate cause for the strike.
Exactly that's, at least that's what the Trump
administration is saying is that they-
they're carrying this out because they believe preventing
chemical weapons use
is in the US national interest.
Allies in the area, in the region, have claimed
that this is a welcome development.
But what they mean by that is that they also
want the Trump administration to start taking
a harder line on the Assad regime.
And they would like to see Trump take further
action against Assad.
So who're the allies in the area that are
pushing for that?
Because, obviously Russia, we assume, not
quite an ally, but in the civil war they are.
Who's pushing for a harder line or more engagement?
Well the Russians are actually pretty unhappy
about this development
because the Russians thought that the Trump administration
would be more open to a negotiated settlement.
The people in the region who are happy are
the Saudis, and the Qataris,
the United Arab Emirates, to a lesser extent Turkey.
These countries that have been pushing to
get Assad out for the last five-six years
and they've been wanting US support that whole
time.
The Obama administration didn't give it to
them.
The question now is whether the strike is
a one-off
or whether Trump is actually going to follow through on that.
It is in this vital national security interest
of the United States
to prevent and deter the spread and use of deadly chemical weapons.
Is he right about that?
That's a difficult question, right?
I mean we think we all benefit from the norm
and indeed the international law against chemical weapons use.
But they're not actually particularly good
weapons of war.
And if you look at the Syrian situation, the
Assad regime killed less than a hundred people
in this chemical weapons attack the other
day.
They've killed thousands, hundreds of thousands
over the last six years,
and yet we don't appear to find that to be a national security interest or problem for us.
So it's really, again, not clear whether Trump
thinks this is a humanitarian intervention
or whether he thinks that it's a security
intervention.
Does he think that we are threatened by Syria's
chemical weapons?
Should the US be doing humanitarian interventions
in Syria? as opposed to-
and that's leaving aside whether or not it is a security one, but-
Absolutely not.
And I think it's really instructive here to
compare Obama and Trump
because they've faced exactly the same situation.
The Assad regime attacking civilians with
sarin gas
and they responded in very different ways.
So Obama is often criticized for that red
line that he made,
it was a really stupid statement,
but he then went on and forged
this really successful diplomatic compromise,
brought in the Russians, they removed the
vast majority of the chemical weapons
and you noticed that for the time that Obama was
in office there was no chemical weapons attack.
It's only now that we have a new president
that the Syrians have decided to test this norm again.
And I don't think a lot of people were satisfied
with Obama's stance toward Syria
because it was- he set the red line and he was pushing for it
and he got pulled back by Rand Paul and Justin Amash
and a couple of other members of Congress.
But it's clear also that going boots in is
not a good idea.
What is the, you know, and more broadly in
the middle east, we invaded Iraq in 2003,
we pulled out in 2011 our combat troops, we're
still involved in the area.
We're now in the third president, in the 21st
century they're three for three
of getting involved in the middle east.
What is the essential lesson that presidents
and both parties
as well as Democrats and Republicans need to learn from,
you know, it's a quagmire, I mean, we're stuck in the middle east.
What is the essential lesson that we need
to learn that we have not yet mastered?
You know, if we go back to that Obama decision
not to intervene in Syria in 2013,
I think it's pretty clear that he had learned the
lessons of Iraq
and particularly of his own failed intervention in Libya.
He looked at both of those and he saw that while
the initial military action might go well,
we end up creating more of a problem than
we actually solve.
And there's actually good academic evidence
that probably more people died in Libya
as a result of the US intervention than if we
just had not intervened in the first place.
So whenever we intervene in these conflicts
we seem to make things worse
and when Obama made his choice on chemical weapons,
he said
'well a diplomatic compromise might be imperfect,
but it's far better than military strikes
that will lead who knows where.'
Trump doesn't seem to have that level of forethought,
he's made the military strikes
and who knows what the next step is?
Well we will leave it there. Thank you.
We've been talking with Emma Ashford at the
CATO Institute, for Reason, I'm Nick Gillespie.